all right so this video is long overdue
but several months ago I had a really
instructive chess lesson with fellow
streamer Hannah says and we covered a
lot of really tricky openings and
approaches uh for white starting with
one E4 we looked at how to play against
Scandinavian Karo Khan and Sicilian it's
a long lesson but I think there's a ton
of value and the time stamp all the kind
of key segments below so feel free to
hop around but also feel free to watch
the whole thing and be sure to check out
Hannah says on Twitch and YouTube and I
really hope you enjoy if you have
questions leave them below don't forget
to subscribe and enjoy the video well do
you have you played the fide rated
tournament yet or not yet
so I've only played like two ever
um oh wow so
nervous when playing over the board I
guess because I've played mostly it's a
natural feeling yeah it takes experience
for for nerds to go away yeah I feel
super comfortable when I'm are playing
online because there's no like stakes in
that but uh sure but then when I get to
over the board tournaments I'm like
shaking and it's really nerve-wracking I
I did I did okay in my first couple but
I had
um I'm very bad at accepting drawers I
had like sort of a that's actually not a
bad thing it's better to play it out
until the end rather than take drugs
cream with truly even if you leave my
chat knows this story in like my first
video reader tolerant ever in my first
round I was paired up against an FM and
I was I was like okay I'm gonna get
crushed and then I realized like maybe
30 moves in or something that I was
winning when he like very begrudgingly
was like too wanna draw
and I was like well no I want to win
this game and then I lost
so that's in hindsight it does sound
like you should have taken the draw but
in the present moment it was a good
choice to play on because not only do
you give yourself the chance of beating
a much higher player but you just learn
more from playing on and then even
though it's it can be painful to lose
um it's a good habit to just play on
especially when higher rate players
offer you a draw yeah it was it was a
little bit it was one of those things
where it was very tilting I guess as
experience yeah it can be tilting
yeah yeah it was like he offered the
draw and then I think it's partly a
psychological thing of right you go well
now I have to win
um then a little while later he's like
you should have accepted the drawer I
was like I probably should have but it's
so easy to say in hindsight but uh I
mean usually when the high area player
offers you a drop means they're in a lot
of trouble I mean the highest rated
player I ever beat in a like slow
Classical tournament he offered me a
draw five five moves before resigning
and I knew that because he was offering
a draw I was much much better at Great
winning chances I turned it down and I
beat him and um well yeah hopefully
you'll get a chance
like that now do you have like an
official feeder rating like if you if
you play your first one and sometimes
you'll get it immediately yeah so I'm
like 1300 at the moment
um and yeah I guess I guess I want to be
improving that you know a lot of people
they I sometimes come into my chat and
they're like how are you 2000 online but
only 1300 over the Vlog I'm like well
it's common I only have a plate over the
blood a couple times so yeah it's the
the reading is coming very drastically
between online and OTB if you especially
if you just play a ton more online so
let's try and just have a game plan for
what to go over so you you had mentioned
you want to learn well you want to learn
gave it lines but more specifically as
white against scandi Sicilian Karo Khan
yes
yes and maybe just general
recommendations too yeah
um yeah so I uh actually between the the
two title Tuesdays I played today I
spent some time trying to just
accumulate some different ideas and
traps and kind of cool recommendations
to show you and
um maybe we can start with a scandi
because it's an opening that you'll
you'll come across maybe not the
majority of the time but uh there's a
lot of players that will play this as
black that uh are like religious
followers of John Bartholomew yeah
um or other creators that uh that vouch
for this candy
and it's sometimes an annoying opening
to deal with because black generally has
a
a pretty straightforward game plan
of like getting some setup with uh just
easy development and um you do kind of
have to know what you're doing as white
now I thought it would be fun to give
you perhaps a few like really trappy
lines
but then also to give you like a an
option of playing
probably what is the most reputable and
from like a very high level the most
challenging line uh okay for uh for
black to to play against
um but perhaps we can start with like
the fun Gambit lines and uh there's a
lot of tactical traps that yeah I
usually just play yeah I've usually just
play like Knight F3 and that sort of
thing and I find it's just really solid
and I just find it difficult to get any
sort of fun attacks or anything against
the skinny yeah Knight F3 is actually
completely fine it's it's played by a
lot of GMS the point is to play D4 C4
and kind of get the the positional space
advantage in the center
um but the more direct move and the move
that I'd recommend for most players is
Knight C3
um just attack the queen immediately and
most players will play Queen A5 here
some players John Bartholomew included
will play Queen d8 which is
um nothing to be too worried about
because then blocks kind of just wasting
time and we can come back to uh to Queen
d8 but um Queen A5 most played
yeah I see this most of the time yeah
yeah and here if you want to be hyper
hyper aggressive there's a Gambit line
that a lot of people at my chat already
screaming to for me to show you is um
it's a pawn sacrifice starts with Pawn
B4
okay and
I will say it's somewhat dubious but it
has a pretty nasty trap to it and even
the black doesn't fall into the Trap you
can get a position with some
compensation
um so we'll look at like the most
critical line Queen takes B4
and every move that white will play from
here on out is uh is making a threat
um so you play Knight B5
threatening C7
most players will play Queen A5 here
and actually the cool thing about this
trap is that
black will play the most popular move
until they fall into the Trap
so here you play Bishop C4
which looks like just an innocent
developing move but you already have
like a pretty nasty threat to this
and the most common move for black is
Pawn C6
which looks really natural just uh
trying to kick away the Knight
but now it's already white to move
something
equation five you you have the right
idea but there's a even better execution
for whites
okay Queen H5 is one candidate move
oh
um
Okay so
I wanted to yeah I wanted to go Queen H5
because yeah threatening the F7 pawn and
also maybe something with a check right
on D6 to try and grab the queen
um what else would there be I mean I
guess you'd have to consider if there's
anything that's sucking the bishop
straight away but it's not really see
anything like that
um
I'm not too sure actually yeah you you
have all kind of the right ideas
um it's just about finding the the
precise line uh you can start with
Bishop F7 this is just more forcing oh
okay and then after King takes
I'll just Queen
actually you go I want you to find uh
the the follow-up here
um
how do we justify the bishop sacrifice
yeah I want to go with a queen check
here
um so Queen F3
where's White going yeah like we have
three nine of six and we kind of run out
of steam
and then also Queen H5 G6
um oh then is there just 19.96 yeah so
it's just not getting black any time to
um to defend
um because we're constantly checking
so it's a really nice use of just using
the whole board and combining the the
tactics and White's favor so yeah that's
a super cool tactic yeah there's been
thousands of players that have fallen
into this online really uh that's
awesome it's very easy just to stumble
into and if black sees the alignment and
sees this move coming there's really not
too much that can be done like if King
E6 is this move again winning yeah
and uh maybe the best try is King F6
but this is just asking for a ton of
trouble there should be two check
and White's having all the fun
like here and you can take with queen
and yeah
yeah if King F7 we win the queen if
Queen if King G6 we check on the back
Rank and just start consuming material
so
yeah so the reason why Bishop 7 is for
Choice it's just more forcing I think
Queen H5 there's some weird move like
King G8 that gives black some chances of
survival because the knight's actually
pinned here
true and it gets a little bit strange
F7 oh well you should not play Queen's
fine we should just play Bishops okay
just sack the bishop yeah and I actually
I had this trap a few years ago against
John Bartholomew who just wasn't aware
of it
um they had a scandi master himself and
he realizes
yeah it seems easy to fall into if or um
playing as black
I think I cut to play anything black
just played the most natural looking
moves yeah
um so I should point out like if that
doesn't stumble into this there's two
main moves that prevent this bishop F7
tactic
um that if black knows what they're
doing or just develops in a normal way
with Knight F6 or Knight C6 uh both of
these moves
um prevent this whole combination
and then then you are down the pond and
this is a risk of playing such a line
that uh you sacrifice material early but
you're still getting a lean development
you'll Castle very soon you can play
Bishop B2 and get the nice Bishops and
uh relatively open position
um and the queen is still a little bit
easier
so it's a nice weapon for uh for Blitz
bullet rapid there is risk in playing it
in slower games but uh it's it's been a
favorite of mine over the the last many
years yeah I think I think these gambits
at least I wanted just to land some
things for Blitz yeah just to be aware
of yeah I have some uh yeah some valence
buttons
so this is a cool one yeah I should also
mention I haven't heard of that either
a six A6 falls into the same drop
like a16 C6 you can kind of just group
together just know you take follow
through with Queen H5 and white is uh
absolutely crushing so I can show you a
few more like really common traps that
if you want to add to like your
blitzcrapper tour they're good ones to
know especially if you haven't seen them
before I don't think there's any just
spend too much time on them but yeah
they're good to be aware of so I want to
show you the tennis and gadgets
which is nice I have seen this but
you've seen this one okay yeah um it's
like Knight G5 Bishop C4 yeah you play
Knight G5 and you've probably seen this
uh it's like the main trap if D3 takes
takes a lot of players go wrong here
with H6 and you know the move for whites
okay let's let me quickly remind myself
I definitely seen it before uh oh wait
so can we just take the pawn on
F7 and then after takes is that Bishop
G6 is that what the exactly yeah this is
called the intercontinental ballistic
missile variation
I'm not sure
it makes for a good like YouTube click
baits
so yeah I wonder what the I wonder why
somebody was like yes let's call it
let's call it the Intercontinental
missile yeah describing the act of the
bishop coming in maybe along with the
Knight
you know I have seen this one before
um
so I could show you one more trap here
which is a bit more advanced
um so just to make sure that everyone
watching understands a reason why this
is so strong for why it is a queen Ang's
in the end so yes it's a common theme
and a lot of opening traps is to deflect
the king away from the queen
um there's yeah there's one more lesser
known trap here
uh is if black plays E5
which is also a very normal looking move
white has a surprising way of punishing
black
and it's definitely a higher level
type of combination but I'll give you
some time to
try and find the best move for white
let me
[Music]
I mean I'd wanna
I'd wanna look at
with a bishop check right and like
um
maybe taking the queen and going for
nine of seven
fork or something but maybe that's I'll
go and see you that's exactly the right
idea
it's just a matter of seeing how black
will react but let's let's play it out
so Bishop B5 check okay
and essentially we kind of have two
threats here because it's obviously
checked to the king but we are
threatening also take and fork
yeah uh so this means black pretty much
has to block on D7
if C6 we can carry through with our um
forking
uh let's say Bishop D7
white to move okay
[Music]
hmm
so with this one
okay I'd want to look at taking fast and
seeing if there's anything with that but
takes maybe just night takes it looks
quite okay
um
what else would that be
also maybe I'd want to look at Queenie
too
just targeting the pawn here but
maybe they just defend or something like
that being a bishop out
[Music]
it's good to look at like the potential
captures and attacks
I want to ask you a question here what
is Block's biggest weakness in the
position
like the biggest kind of song seven Pawn
right so this is where we should be kind
of focusing our thoughts now Knight
takes F7 immediately it just loses a
night yeah hey you got one Shack but
it's not gonna lead so much
yeah
but sometimes the best way to explore
the weakness is just to attack it
okay
so maybe
you see full
something like that
um yeah one person in my chat said Queen
D5 attack
25 would be nice if the Knight wasn't
there yeah there's a V4 much more
accurate
and black just doesn't have a good way
to defend the pawn yeah because then if
The Bishop's going to E6 that's just
probably not looking nice at all yeah
actually at Bishop V6 we can simplify
and with material by taking the queen
first take the bishop and then fork and
then yeah at the end fights winning
a lot of material
so this is a nice one this is usually
not shown too often in YouTube videos
that cover like the intercontinental
ballistic missile but it's a great one
to know because it's it's a little bit
strange to like move here and then move
here but the whole point was something
to come to D7
uh to avoid the immediate trade of
queens and then that bishop or Knight
blocks
uh it's the same thing just Bishop C4
and black is in major trouble
yeah
it's nice for what yeah I definitely
heard of that um
before like the Knight F7 Bishop G6 trap
that I hadn't sure I hadn't heard of
this one at all so yeah that's a cool
one yeah so the the bishop g61 uh
there's been I was tracking the numbers
earlier there's been over 50 000 players
who've walked into it online
yeah if you include like all the
different chess platforms so okay let's
see how many of my opponents fall into
it hopefully fifty thousand of my
opponents fall into this trap too that's
yeah if you play enough chess over the
next uh a few few decades then you'll
get to that number
I could show you one more it's it's a
fun Gambit line it's another one of
these like super
maybe not super common but super
aesthetic opening traps that just
and then we're gonna see a common theme
where the point plays naturally and they
just stumble into a landmine
um okay and it also starts from the
scandi more common you can get it from a
like a queen's Pawn
uh it's a BlackMart gamer
so Blackmore dimer is uh it's like D4 in
this position you basically transpose
and the line I'll show you it's called
the rider Gambit which happens after
Pawn Jake's Pawn
you attack the pawn
black defends and then you play F3
yep uh back will normally take
and it looks natural to take with the
Knights but the Ryder Gambit is where
you take with the queen and you give
away
your d-pawn
um and the reason for doing this is to
get a lot of initiative
um especially with the black queen in
the center to develop a tempo
uh I think most players play Queen B4
here
kidding okay the b-pawn
You Queen side Castle
yeah so already like very fast
development for whites goth open file
and here it looks like Bach has a nice
tactic Bishop G4
looks like black swings yeah
however you hit black with a really
really nice move
um I think I'll just show you the move
is it a rook sack it's a queen sack uh
Queen sack okay maybe I'll let you find
it actually lights to move soccer yeah I
I love sacrificing my queen
um okay
[Music]
okay there's only there's only a couple
ways to sacrifice the queen here so I
maybe I'll see if there's anything with
Queen F6 first queen of six
and takes
um
I wanna I wanna be able to find it you
you said there's a couple ways to sack
the queen but there's actually there's a
lot of ways to give the queen
and there's a lot of ways I don't want
to like
I don't want to encourage you to have
the wrong thought process because I
already give you gave you like a major
clue but yeah the I think the common
thing to understand
is that
sometimes when a when a queen is
attacked
the only justifiable way to leave your
queen attacked is to make a stronger
threat
which is either attacking your
opponent's Queen
or
checking your opponent's king or
threatening mate
so you should be looking for like major
threats here
okay so I mean I guess we have one check
here so we'll look at the check
um
check C6
C6 and then your your bishop and queen
are both hanging yeah and that's a lot
of things hanging or 95.
attacking the queen
um
95 takes
how else can I attack
um okay I'll give you which I need uh I
think a bit more helpful
925 looks cool
um it looks like a cool move but yeah
okay first of all I I want you to uh
she look into this line because Knight
D5 you you mentioned you're attacking
the queen
what would you do if Bishop takes Queen
Bishop
[Music]
takes that Queen that's
um Bishop takes D1 and then we're just
in trouble but what about
um Knight takes
seven it's just mates Knight C7
contrasting techniques yeah
so you
um yeah you're actually you're having
the right idea of of going after you see
seven
um although Knight D5 allows Knight
takes D5
yeah and then
that actually gets a bit weird
but I think Block's doing okay here
and this bishop's still defended by the
queen if you take the Rook is lost so
it's much better not uh play Knight D5
but um
yeah yeah
and not only are we threatening made in
one
but we're also abstracting this queen
from covering B7
yeah which is relevant in the coming
line because okay first of all black
doesn't have too many ways to
defense E7
uh the most common move here is Knight
A6 which uh okay yeah it just depends
upon maintaining the skewer
okay but now because uh B7 is hanging we
just take it we'll just take yeah and
White's having all the fun hitting the
Rook
threatening voice mates
and most players here play Rook B8 Rook
B8 yeah yeah
and it's it's a messy position because a
lot is happening Queen's attacks Knight
defends a rook might also defends the C7
Pawn rook's hanging
however there's there's a way to just
end things immediately and this is white
to move and force mates
a false mate
well
I'd be thinking about Queen C6 check
uh
Bishop comes back probably though
um
it could take this Pawn over here with
check
but then after night takes I guess
Black's threatening mate on B2
um
maybe we take the Knight on A6
depends this ah there's so many so
there's a lot of options yeah I'll say
it's it's horse made in two
so really the first move has to be a
check a Check Yes and you've okay you've
you considered Queen C6 which just runs
into vlogging there's no mates yeah you
have to consider the other possible
seven Knight C7 then Knight takes C7
yeah and then so what are the other
candidate moves
I like candidate moves well there's not
many checks left or you can take the
Rook oh
take the Rook
wait take the brook Knight takes and
then just yeah it's a clean shot device
it's interesting like how how the brain
works is sometimes you just
unconsciously reject a move that loses a
queen but it's always worth it a little
bit further yeah and seeing um it's the
same mating idea of The Rook cutting off
yeah I just kind of forgot that that was
a thing yeah so like already after Queen
takes B7 black is pretty much toast
yeah there there's maybe some ways for
for Block to survive but White's uh
having a decisive Advantage here
and
there's been I think there's been
hundreds of players that have walked
into this one
so again like the a lot of the moves for
black they were just very natural and uh
as white coming up with these very
exotic uh sacrifices and tactics yeah
this is this looks like a lot of fun
so so anyway I gave you uh what did I
give you the um the first one which was
this B4 Gambit
that was actually called the Leonard's
gambits and then the tennis and Gaba
traps and then the the Black mardemer
Rider gambits so a few ones to uh keep
in your arsenal of opening tricks yeah
there's a lot of cool ones I feel like
the tennis in Gambit for some reason I
feel like a lot of people know
how to defend against that but maybe
maybe it's more common that's one of the
issues at a certain level uh players are
just a bit more have have a bit more
experience and have raised raised or
grown through the Rings to know how to
avoid the traps there but you'll still
get traps on occasion with with Tennyson
yeah I like I like the beef full one
though because I've actually never heard
of that um I've seen black vandima and I
think I've played a few times just
because I like to play random gambits
without even knowing what they are and
see if I can win but I've always gone
for night takes on C3 or Knight F3 first
sorry yeah taking in the in the Blackman
team are taking with them okay gotcha
yeah the rider Gambit is a bit less
common that uh sometimes it has more
surprise value yeah
um I could show you like the main like
the the more reputable approach to
playing for uh for white if you want
like one more like
non-dubious just
uh uh objectively good line that has a
trap in it
um yeah let's go that is probably more
suitable for slower chess and it still
involves this queen A5 line okay
yeah and
it happens after some common moves D4
Knight F6 and I have three
and a lot of players here will play
Bishop G4
um actually extremely common for black
to
um develop the bishop before they block
it in with E6
yeah yeah
and here's a key to actually getting
initiative in this line because a lot of
players would be maybe inclined to start
developing their Bishops but it's
important to throw in this move H3
okay and you're forcing the bishop to
kind of make up its mind
um if Bishop takes F3 you're happy just
to take back and you got the bishop pair
you activate your queen
um most players will play Bishop H5
yeah now actually I'm remembering
another trap too I wasn't planning to
show you this one but I probably should
uh okay just so you're aware of it there
is a move through Queen H5
oh yeah which looks kind of cool
actually I've yeah I've had people play
this against me before actually like
this exact line and what would you do in
this position I've always just played
Bishop E2 yeah is there some crazy
there's there's a better movie as far as
I remember
uh you can just take the bishop
yeah okay and you can say oh no my Rook
but when they take the Rook
then Knight E2
I believe and Knight G3 is coming
yeah and I don't know if black can
like has an easy way to prevent this
if we look at Knight G3 uh you'd be
controlling all the squares and like
hitting the queen in the corner yeah
you're controlling H5
and there's no safe moves currently like
the Queen's already stuck
yeah that's interesting
the only move I'm seeing for black is an
attempt is 94.
Knight G3 but I think you can just play
Queen D3
hitting the knights and there doesn't
seem to be a great way to defend the
Knight and Knight Retreats you still
have Knight G3
so this is very good to know because I
actually come across this uh surprising
amount so I thought it was you know uh I
I guess I had considered taking at some
point but usually I've just gone for the
safe route because it doesn't when you
look like you're losing a rook then it
seems a bit scary so right and a lot of
players think they're so clever like
putting their Queen here pinning and uh
yeah actually both directions creating
the battery but uh yeah this is about
players terribly for luck yeah it looks
impossible to take so that's good to
know awesome so yeah another uh another
tactical Motif but most players will
play Bishop G Bishop to H5
yeah and here you kind of break some
opening principles because most openings
you just try and develop in Castle as
quickly as possible but here because you
haven't committed to kausing yet you can
keep expanding with G4 the G4 yeah and
after Bishop G6
you break another opening principle and
move the same piece twice but it's all
with good intention you play Knights E5
95 and
it looks like you might be going after
the bishop but you're actually
interested in playing Knight C4 to try
and trap the queen
and as far as I know this is supposed to
be a really good line for whites
and the clock's not careful there's a
lot of ways a queen can just run into
trouble
like E6 looks like a very natural move
but after
Knight C4 I don't know how black is
actually saving the queen
yeah it doesn't look like it has many
squares to go to there's A6
all all other squares like you're
controlling the whole fifth rank
yeah I guess I guess most players would
maybe just go to A6 so A6 aligns with
the the bishop on F1 yeah and this is
sometimes a frustrating type of
situation where it looks like you're
gonna have a strong Discovery this
should be a tactic yeah like you want to
play Knight D6 but then Queen takes E6
so what you can do here is just leave
the tension not move your knight and
make a simple threat actually simple
something yeah yeah fish about four
sorry covering the D6 Square uh
threatening Knight D6
and I think black is just toast here
like there's no good way to get the
queen out of trouble
yeah this looks really nice
although there is Queen wait a minute
Queen C6
I maybe spoke too soon
Queen C6 are we getting oh
there's a funny line Queen C6 hits a
rook
I'm not using an engineer so I've yeah
on my own I was thinking you can still
play Knight D6
and whatever it takes it you're gonna
have Bishop B5
oh that's fine if King D7 still Bishop
B5 I'm not sure about King E7 though
because you're you're rook and Knight
are hanging and things get messy
everything's hanging
I actually don't know how to toggle the
engine this would be a case where I just
ask like stockfish yeah no I can't see
how to turn it on hmm
and I'll go ahead and say like I I first
learned about this line back when I was
eight years old uh my first chess coach
taught me this this exact uh 95 and
Knight C4 idea
and I have a lot of lessons when I was
younger reviewing these lines
um so I should like I should remember
what I was taught as a kid but
yeah
um I think someone also said in chat
which is a move
that maybe I was looking at too so after
and King E7 something with like D5 Maybe
um
but yeah okay I've cheated a little bit
I've turned on the engine
okay and it turns out this this line
isn't actually that great for whites the
best move is Rook G1
and maybe okay it's still playable
engine gives roughly equal
um
this position is really good for white
yeah
so I wonder what we're meant to do
ah it's not as good as I okay so the
best approach is actually to trap the
bishop or to try and trap the bishop
with each four going for each five and
uh I guess what would black play if
black just plays yeah
then we can return to E5
okay and you're hitting the queen with
the bishop and you're you're just
threatening to destroy black skin
that does look nice yeah
um anyway so this this was just supposed
to be like an introductory uh line that
uh if you want something a bit more
stable that uh still has some some Venom
to it then this is yeah I like it
because a lot of the times against the
Scandia I just feel like black it's a
very solid physician dress me and I just
um obviously when I'm playing it as
white I want to be attacking a little
bit more
um so yeah for sure it's a nice one
today I thought maybe we can move on to
Sicilian or Caro Khan I think yes I
would like that
I I did actually do some research on
your own repertoire like what you play
in your online games
and I saw against Carol Khan you like to
play the panel of baphunic attack
C4 yes
yes it's just actually a nice like
active line I used to play it myself as
white uh for many years had some good
results with it
um I also play the Fantasy as well
okay but yeah fantasy has some Venom to
it
yeah it's not something I specialize in
but it's a it's a nice weapon if you
know what you're doing is white
yeah
um
yeah and I'll admit that there's not too
many like legitimate legitimately
legitimately good gambits that you can
play against the Carroll Khan
um because it's a more solid opening for
black I'll make you aware of one line
that if you just want to have fun and
play an opening with a cool name there's
something called the hillbilly
that starts with Bishop to C4 C4 yes I
probably wouldn't recommend playing this
because you're just inviting D5 yeah but
the point is that you play Bishop B3 you
sack your e-pawn
and then you play Queen H5
and you get a lot of activity most
players will play E6 or G6
it's like the fancy Scholars May attack
yeah you're just trying to get F7 this
could work against beginners maybe like
maybe some people would play Knight F6
yeah um I I hope nobody at Miley would
play it but who knows yeah most most
stronger players will play G6
yeah but then you play Queen H4
and whatever black does to develop you
can go for F3
and this has some similarity to uh a
black mardemer where you get kind of the
the black pawn taking and you get the
open file and then there's potential to
attack in the middle game with castling
and
um eventually bringing your Bishop to H6
uh combined with your Bishop on B3 there
there is Middle game potential for uh
for attacking yeah this this looks fun
when I when I play uh the fantasy I do
usually try and get into these kind of
it's so similar yeah yeah with um the
open f file just going for this
because I feel like that's the most fun
yeah this does look fun there's there's
um there's another line in Sicilian the
Grand Prix attack
I've actually seen you play a few times
which has basically the same setup
um here you're getting it a bit earlier
but you combine
um these pieces and Bishop H6 is very
common in Grand Prix as well
at the time I just play a lot of random
openings without knowing anything about
them so I noticed that but that's
actually a good thing you get to
experience different structures and
um it doesn't get too redundant if
you're mixing it up once in a while it's
so much fun I love it so much
um but yeah sometimes it gets me into
trouble when my opponent's like super
booked up and I'm just like I'm just
gonna play a random move here
so the the one thing I recommend to a
lot of players against Carol Khan which
I think is uh the most trappy but also
one of the most reputable lines that a
lot of Grandmasters play
is called the two nights attack
that
I I noticed you've never played in your
life at least on chess.com yes I've
never played This is the sell-up
okay and
I I didn't start playing this until much
later in my chess career
but the reason why I began playing this
was because of the potential traps
and the Venom that that it has if black
is somewhat unprepared
um I'll just start by showing you like
the main trap and even if you don't have
this as your your main weapon against
Kuro Khan it's something to keep in mind
because there's a lot of amateur players
that will treat this like a classical
variation
the classical is when white has a Pawn
on D4 and the Knight cell back on G1
and the main line in that position is
Bishop F5
it turns out by five in this
position is actually a pretty
significant mistake
oh okay
uh and the reason why is because you can
generate
a lot of initiative against the bishop
yeah and once black plays Bishop G6
black is already in a lot of trouble
can you continue here with H4
threatening to drop the business
yes most players play H6
and then you play 95 so it's it's pure
initiative
hitting the bishop
and it's mainly positional threat like
get the bishop hair destroyed block
structure
almost everyone plays this move
and now you keep throwing punches you
play Queen H5
threatening mate
um Bach pretty much has to play G6 this
is
this is a sad move but it's the best
yeah I didn't really see anything else
that the alternative would be Queen
D5 but this runs into Bishop C4
oh I might just crashing here
and now yeah after G6 it gets fun
because you don't have to move your
queen
oh find the best move
which is not a queen move
well
Bishop C4 is on my mind now obviously
threatening this which would be
absolutely wonderful if anybody just
took the queen and yes yeah you can play
Bishop C4 and say oh no my queen
most people will be aware of the threats
I've had like I've had one game online
where my opponent took the queen
um the reason why they took the queen uh
in the one game I played like a year ago
was I played Bishop C4 instantly so they
thought it was like a accident like a
pre-move yeah that sort of thing oh
that's that's smart but most players
will be aware of the main threat they'll
play E6
and now you actually have to move your
queen
and yeah Queen F3 seems like the natural
move to keep the threat the threats
going
yeah but the move I would suggest here
is Queen E2
and you make a sneakier type of threat
where you're not immediately threatening
mates
but you're making it so maybe
threatening Knight F7 yeah Knight of
seven and queen E6 is actually super
deadly
that looks fun and you're making it so
that a lot of natural developing moves
for rock just walk into this exact
combination
like Knight F6 Bishop G7
Knight D7 Bishop D6 all the moves I've
highlighted walk into Knight F7
yeah
and I've seen a lot of like strong
players like expert and above just
stumble into this and then Black's just
losing King takes us 67 the move for
black instead yeah black has to do
something a little bit awkward like
Queen
um Queen C7 or queen F6 are probably the
the two main moves or queen E7
yeah
um against any of these moves you just
play D4
so if we imagine Queen C7 D4
and you haven't won any material but
you're just having an amazing position
the Knight on D4 looks awesome yeah
blacks only develop minor piece is a sad
Bishop on each side yeah this bishop
looks very sad and these pawns are all
kind of
looking a bit weird over here yeah G6
Pawn just blocks from the bishop you're
gonna align your Bishop with the queen
probably Queen side castle and enjoy
life
yeah that looks like that looks like a
lot of fun so so that's if that's only
if that's if they walk into it the
problems really start with the bishop I5
because if they play Bishop by five
they're likely to play Bishop G6 here
yeah yeah
um now there are some other
uh options for black
some people will play Bishop G4
after which you play H3
if they take you're happy just activate
your queen get the bishop pair
um have more developments
and the reason I'm showing you this sign
is because after Bishop H5 you play
Knight G3 as they play Bishop G6 this is
a direct transposition into what we just
saw oh just the same thing yeah you you
wasted a Tempo playing h3h4 but black
waves the tempo like moving the bishop
so many times
yeah and uh yeah that's a lot of Bishop
moves yeah and again you go straight
into this line Bishop C4
so there's a few other kind of trappy
lines like if you play two knights
attack
um some lines are a bit more positional
and if we try and cover our bases here
like if black plays D4
this is a position that you shouldn't
worry too much about not too many
players will play this move and if they
do you just play Knight E2
uh C5 is most played and then Knight G3
and then all you have to know is Bishop
C4 D3 Castle you have really stable
position your Knights are not only good
Defenders for your king but good
attackers
yeah
and uh yeah your Bishop actually both
Bishops will be very happy developed
yeah Bishop outside the pawn chain
yeah D3 Fest and then it looks really
cramped but yeah
Bishop C4 first Sometimes Bishop B5 but
uh yeah White's having fun here and
there there's a bonus trap like if if
Knight C6 yay let's say Bishop uh C4
yeah bonus trap is if they play Bishop
G4 oh is this the
um yeah I know this
is that yeah if The Bishop's not
defended then you can go for this yeah
yeah
thinking there's being so brilliant and
sacking their Queen and then mates oh
yeah but but this fails to uh yeah
Knight takes E5 and then all of a sudden
you just lost a piece
oh no
that's something I do in bullet or
something and be like Yay where you like
you you hope you're you're being
brilliant but uh but really nice
so yeah if you just know 92 and then
know some arrows you'll be good to go in
this line
awesome
um
so
I'm trying to think what else black can
play here that's common there's a few
other options after
takes takes and then actually a common
line is Knight F6
yep
um the so-called
there's a similar line called the TARTA
tower that Levy actually recommends is
he he's a big hero con fan
yes
the the idea for black is to get a
structure with double pawns but really
solid position and where black will play
Bishop D6 and castle
and it's hard to crack the um the setup
so rather than taking there's a cool
move here Queenie too
okay which at first it kind of looks
like hope chess
and it kind of there's part of this
which is Hope Chest you're hoping black
plays Knight D7 and then you you kind of
blend is the yeah yeah
um but Queenie 2 is actually one of the
best moves for White and the point is
you're threatening to take and
preventing the epon from taking back
oh yeah
oh yeah then so you're trying to make it
so black takes with the g-pawn
um so if it moves like there's about
five is played you're happy to get a
structure like this where it's not so
attractive for black to Castle on the
king side
yeah
oh you said E6 for black
E6 oh sorry I I think I cut you off you
said some some move or maybe I was just
hearing things
yeah I think I think I think you might
be hearing things unless I don't
remember saying something no worries
um I was gonna say the the main line
here is Knight takes E4
and then takes
and then a lot of players will bring
their Knight into try and hit your queen
yeah and here you have another
oh no my queen idea of Bishop C4
and you don't move your queen but you
play Knight E5 95 yeah and again it's
not easy to to trap players uh this
position most most will be aware of the
threat hey yeah it's it's staring them
right in the face if they miss it yeah
but the nice thing about including 95 is
you're essentially provoking E6
and then the bishop is just shot in and
then you move your queen back and you
have more activity and a more pleasant
location
nice
so yeah there's some early tactical
nuances in these lines but uh
it's uh it's nice to know for white I'll
share one more trap with you and then
maybe we can move on to Sicilian yeah
yeah awesome there's a move here Bishop
I'm loving all of these
good to hear yeah there's a move here
Bishop said G4
and there's actually a few options here
if you want to just have a a very stable
position H3 is usually the go-to move
takes takes E6 and then I can recommend
the setup with um D3 G4 Bishop G2 is a
interesting way of playing
but if you want to set a trap
there's a move Bishop E2
and when you play Bishop E2 you're
making it so D4 looks more attractive
for black because a knight can't go to
E2
oh yeah but G4 is actually a big mistake
yeah
and you you spot the move for whites
yes yeah this is like a very common Rush
idea yeah
and uh yeah if Queen takes you in the
bishop and if Bishop takes you can
actually take with either Knight here
and you've yeah it looks like yeah I
think that people might actually play
them at my level maybe people
um yeah D4 is one of the most played
moves
um I think more common is something like
E6
yeah
but then you can actually keep the the
Trap alive like you can castle and
you're still waiting for them to play D4
so you can just take
and okay eventually if they uh if they
decide not to take you can I think you
can probably go for the spacecraft yeah
I have an ID for yourself
nice
um
anyway this was just meant to be a
starting point
uh yeah or the two nights attack and I
have a whole video covering lines in the
two nights attack as white against the
Carroll Khan
so if you want even more traps uh you
can search YouTube for crush the carocon
and my my videos should come up
among the first few few searches
awesome now Levy has a video how to
crush with the Karo Khan
so uh they're they're kind of competing
make sure not to accidentally click on
that one yeah I uh I I show lines that
he didn't cover in his video so oh okay
so I got the secret information there's
some secret trap sir exactly cool
awesome well it seems like there's a lot
in this I've I've actually yeah I've
never tried the two knights attack so
yeah it's one that uh I mean it just
follows opening principles because you
you accelerate development and
um it's not like the other lines like
pan off or Advanced variation where
you're pushing a lot of Pawns early
so yeah sometimes when you develop your
nights earlier it leads to more tactics
and more traps
um
and there's also a two nights attack
against a French defense
which has very similar ideas to Karo
Khan
yeah against the French I play
just the Knight C3
variation oh sure so like 9.3 okay
because I love going into that
um poison variation of the Winola yeah
okay so fun that's a good weapon then
yeah and probably just stick with that
um
so yeah if you want to move on to
Sicilian
I will admit the Sicilian is it's one of
these lines
that can Branch out in so many different
ways
I know that it was hard for me to
even narrow down
like specific trappy lines to show
because there's just so many different
things black can do
I checked your repertoire
and it seems like you play a lot of the
the main lines for light like you you
willingly go into open Sicilian
um I saw you're playing like Bishop G5
nardorf and some Mainline dragons
um yeah I yeah I pretty much solely go
for open Sicilian
um yeah with D4 just because I I think
it's a lot of fun the games like I just
always like to Castle queenside and push
on my pawns
I've sort of gotten to the point where
sometimes sometimes I just don't want to
play versus Sicilian I played it I
played like a bazillion English attacks
and I kind of want to have something a
little bit different to other types of
weapons yeah exactly exactly because you
know the English attack it's fun but
when you play it every single game
because I think also especially uh at my
ear around 2000 I think so many people
play the Sicilian
um that's one of the most common
defenses that you'll run into yeah and
when you play with Sicilian there's uh
like at least a dozen different lines
black can choose between
um yeah so it can be it can be rewarding
actually like if you play open Sicilian
as white and you you it seems like
you've accumulated a lot of experience
in playing these like open fun attacking
positions
but it's also challenging from a
repertoire standpoint where there's a
lot of things to be prepared for and as
you play Stronger players they're gonna
know what they're doing in kind of
exactly these main lines and they just
know they're Sicilian and I've got to
learn what to play against everybody
else's Sicilian and sometimes it's like
well I guess it can just be pretty easy
to be outmatched maybe if somebody is
very familiar with exactly but yeah so
one one thing comes to mind to give you
a weapon to integrate in your overall
repertoire and what I'm going to show
you it allows you to go into open
Sicilian if you want but it also like it
gives you some more options in terms of
the um the positions you can reach
and
we'll start with D6 because this is
probably the most common move you're
running into of course there's E6 Knight
C6 which we can look at but D6 usually
means that black is going for ignitor
dragon or classical Sicilian
yeah D6 is by far
the my
number and like most players just to
explain uh most players will get to this
position play Knight C6 or Knight F6 for
vote Knight C3 and this is nardorf
dragon and classical
yeah so there's a way to
kind of bunch all of these lines
together or or be prepared for someone
who plays either night or classical
dragon by starting with the move Knight
C3
because most players will play Knight F6
um just being ready to transpose back
into open Sicilian
and the line I I want to show you I
don't know if it has a name
um oh
I'm not seeing any names.com is
generating here but it's a move E5 in
this position
cool and this is a line I actually
prepared recently uh for this match
against James Canty this uh like I am
not a GM yes yes I did watch that and we
played this line in one game
and he got a losing position in like uh
within the first 10 moves
um unfortunately I didn't punish him I
think I still won that game though but
it's a very venomous line especially for
Blitz because White's getting uh very
quick activity and initiative of course
you start by hitting the knights
and it's also not that dubious like even
if black plays perfectly it's still a
reasonable position for white
um almost everyone will take
and you take back with knights
and the way I actually became aware of
this line is
I have a friend who's rated around like
23 2400 he's a feeding master and I saw
him about a year ago
uh he was telling me a story about how
he played Daniel neridiski in one of
these like speed run videos that Daniel
was doing
and he trout Dania in like 12 moves
oh and that's awesome he was playing on
like a Smurf account so my friend's
reading on his Smurf account was like
1200 and Dania just thought he was a
complete Noob and uh took free material
and then got in trouble
so I can show you the Trap that he uh he
caught Daniel with
um which is actually a really beautiful
trap
yeah
yeah I don't know Dania knows this
backstory
but uh hopefully I can remember it it
starts with black playing Pawn Asics
which is actually a logical move because
it discourages Bishop B5 and that's one
of the intentions of your knight here is
you wanted to try and control these
squares potential potential blocking
squares
yeah and here you can play
um a Nifty move Pawn G3
which
aims to develop the bishop to the long
diagonal because you you don't really
want to develop your Bishop here and
then eventually walk into B5
um so Bishop is going to stand very
nicely on G2
a lot of players will play Queen C7
including ganya
hitting the knights
and now you just uh you defend the
Knight with D4
very common resource in this opening
there will be a trade takes takes and
here it looks very natural for black to
just hit your queen with knights C6
okay
and this is exact position that my
friend Halligan's Tanya he was still
prepared he took the knights
and after Queen digs night
it actually looks good for a block at
first because the queen is hitting the
rook and there's no vision
but here there's a really surprising
move for white
you can just develop your Bishop to G5
and completely ignore the fact that your
Rook is hanging
yeah and then if Queen takes and queen
takes H1 is exactly what Dania played
um thinking it looks like a free rook
but after queenside Castle
Weiss was completely winning here
uh how how to stop Queen DJ checkmate
not to mention there's ideas of Bishop
B5
yeah I mean I guess I guess
Black's got to like move the bishop out
maybe to get the Rook defending the back
rank right yeah like Bishop D7 looks
like the safe move
but then Bishop takes F6 so then yeah we
won back some material
um if you turn on the engine here it's
already like plus five for white so it's
it's a Nifty trick and it can catch
players that are maybe overly greedy
oh for sure yeah no I I feel like I can
definitely uh see how Daniel would just
be thinking oh yeah he's 1200 he just
Blended a room yeah sometimes when you
play your opponents reading and not uh
not realize the danger in the position
yeah so this is one of those lines that
just inspired me to look closer at the
opening
um
and this opening it's like it's a a line
that you can play without needing to do
too much like if they play A6 you
develop your Bishop this way
if they play something like
um
like Knight D7 is another
attempt to try and uh
pressure white from early on
yeah and this is where you can actually
play Pawn D4
and invite a queen trade
so if takes takes you get some nice
activity you don't mind like takes takes
your queen is actually quite pretty
strong in the center and Bishop B5 is
coming
okay
and there's a cool line that uh can
happen after
Knight takes E5
takes E5
hitting the knights now if the Knight
moves like G4 you you take the queen you
take away box casting rights
so most players will take on D1
and then you take back with the King
and then there's a really crazy line
here I'm gonna try and remember it it's
been a few weeks since I reviewed this
but uh most players almost all players
will play Knight G4 yeah
looks scary because you lost casting
rights your pawns are forked yeah but
then you have Bishop B5 check
uh-huh black has two legal moves Bishop
D7 is most natural
yeah and then after White's next move it
guarantees why a nice Advantage it
actually makes things really messy but
it almost all goes in White's favor is
Pawn B6
oh
where that's very spicy very spicy move
you're you're hitting the bishop
there's some positional idea that if
black takes
then you just get a much more pleasant
uh like queenless middle game or almost
already an end game after something like
takes takes key to you are down a pond
but this the structure combined with the
fact work D1 will come with Tempo should
be very nice for whites
does look nice yeah and then
of course there's there's a lot of
options for black here if um if Knight
takes F2
you play King E2
and then if the Rook is grabbed I think
this is completely winning for light you
take
with a pawn
and at the very least you're gonna trap
the knights and have two pieces yeah
just develop the bishop yeah
um yeah we're coming in
so I think most players will
instead of the take on F2 take on B5
yeah and then you take back now of
course you're no longer threatening the
bishop but you're threatening the fork
yeah
yeah so if black goes for the fork
you just Fork right back
and it's a lot easier for you to win the
nylon H1 than it is for Black to win the
Knight here because you have this
resource Bishop 4927.
all right yeah
I know we're going through a lot but a
lot of this is some stuff you can kind
of figure out uh over there no it does
make sense which is nice like the It
doesn't feel like any of these lines uh
things where I just have to be
memorizing it like crazy there's a lot
of Vlogs yeah intuitive I guess yeah
um so the last thing to acknowledge is
if black queens like castles
and this is a common theme you just play
King E2 you defend your Pawn Yeah if
they take it's similar to that other
line where you are temporarily down the
pawn
but you have a much better structure
this bishop is slow to develop
um I'm not sure what the best move here
is you might be able to just win the
pawn actually
like you win back the point right away I
was thinking we could probably could
just take and then no matter where the
king moves you come back
up
then A4 looks nice
and actually I'm remembering now this
this exact line is what I had in my uh
prep file for James Canty okay and just
like in general for this line so and did
you get this did you get this is this
the line that I didn't get this line
during the game
um I wonder if I can quickly find the
game
let me see if I can find the game
against Canty because it was a nice one
uh I would love to see you
I think it was in the bullet portion
congrats on yeah oh thanks so much yeah
um yeah
I I was very thankful to have just made
it through all so many strong players
if your plane was very like very good
players so that was very impressive I
was watching pretty much all of them and
I was like Yay Eric
appreciate that yeah um I mean I put a
lot more preparation into the matches
compared to previous years so I think
that helped
um especially when it comes to like
opening preparation
um but then another part of it was just
making sure I was getting sleep before
the matches and like in Peak mental form
like eating well uh exercising a few
days leading up so a lot of things came
together
it's crazy how much of a difference that
makes I find the same if I'm playing a
match with someone like if I don't get a
good sleep the night before it's really
um
it really changes how I play and also
also your morale going into the match as
well like I noticed that you are very
good if you've lost a couple of games
you're very good at bouncing back trying
to avoid the tones yeah and yeah
yeah which is a thing that not a lot of
people
you know uh find that easy it's tough
yeah that's like just yeah because most
players play their best chess when
they're calm and if you get emotional
either between games or during a game
you're like you blunder you really have
to
um to just accept the fact that okay you
can't undo the past and just try and
be in the present moment and play the
best moves possible
yeah yeah you're playing great I also
saw yeah there was one there was one
match I noticed
um where you had that it was some London
prep which was oh maybe against Tanya
like she kept walking into the same
thing yeah yeah yeah she and she's a
very very good player so that was that
was a really cool one to watch
um yeah she she has like a very
classical and uh stable repertoire but
uh I was able to find a few holes in a
repertoire that uh you know she she
didn't quite prepare for her so it was
nice to
kind of punish the openings as much as
possible
yeah that was really good I was almost
like after that I was like I kind of
want to play the London now but
yeah it's it's a it's a fun opening and
it has kind of a misunderstood
reputation a lot of people hate on the
London think it's boring but there's
there's a way of playing it to make the
positions really exciting and there's so
many traps
um if if you're well prepared
and a lot of people just underestimated
to
oh for sure yeah
wait a minute I've seen this game I
thought I found the right game but maybe
I didn't
different game yeah
no this is a Dirty Harry game he played
H5
which maybe some like maybe you would
run into uh as
as white if you ever play James Canty
I could show you this too because like
if you're an open ceiling player
uh maybe a very small percentage of your
teams you'll you'll encounter this move
well I try
to find really popular
by
Ali Reza or something like that
um so a lot of people have been playing
uh H5 and there's later positions too
like ignite or even Dragon because it
slows down the English attack
yeah
yeah I like I knew he played this before
the match and I prepared a very rare
move it's actually one of the engine's
hot choices Bishop F4
yeah
um
maybe getting inspiration from the
London opening because The Bishop's
actually really well placed here
and the point is that if black tries to
undermine the bishop they're in the fork
uh White can take and then play E5 just
open the center this is really good for
whites
and the game he got into trouble really
quickly uh allowing the dark squares to
become really good yeah yeah that and I
had to play E5 and then
um that I just invaded dark squares and
this was crushing already for white
so yeah I found the other game I wanted
to show you though uh okay I downloaded
the wrong one
and pacing in the PGN I think I'll just
show you the bullet game this was a
bullet game but it featured
this nameless opening that uh yeah
yeah that I was very happy to get
and well I just showed you featured like
that clean trade line
was the trade in Knights and then trade
of Queens
yeah yeah if we review this let me just
see if you remember the key move after
your takes takes
Knight G4 do you remember what white
should play here
so
um we should go Bishop B5 checks oh and
Bishop D7 yes
um so the move is easy very good okay
yeah making sure uh that information is
is staying yeah yeah I am I'm
so this position
on D4
which I was also prepared for took back
yeah he took
oh so I actually had mentioned the sign
to you uh it's uh it's Pleasant for
white the queen is strong yeah
um
he played Pawn E6
and then Bishop B5 check so I'm just
developing the tempo
Bishop D7
but I I think around
wait a minute
I'm pretty sure it was this position
Bishop B5 looks nice but I'm pretty sure
there is a stronger move
oh okay and
I'll actually give this to you as an
exercise let me just check
oh I'm actually wrong Bishop B5 is is uh
one of the top moves
um
I'll still give this to you as kind of a
an exercise what's the other candidate
move for white that you should consider
be considering in this position I would
be considering Bishop G5 and Knight P5
yeah Knight B5 is uh
is probably one of the more direct
options just going for C7 yeah
um I haven't looked at this too closely
with the engine but it gives a
significant Plus for white and really
puts clock on the back foot
yeah uh what happened in the game I
played Bishop B5 Bishop B7 Bishop G5
and then he played A6
and it was this position I missed an
opportunity I I took on D7 thinking oh
uh the knights pinned he has to take
with Queen
you get the double pawns yeah but I miss
the fact he could take with knights and
counter-attack my queen
oh yeah I had the same thought process
too I was like oh this looks easy this
looks really nice after six yeah and
White's still doing fine here like
probably slightly better but uh there is
a missed opportunity
so the question is what is a stronger
move for white in this position
[Music]
well maybe we could take the night
straight away
yeah it's just a matter of mixing the
move order you take the mic right away
and if Pawn takes check and then move
the queen I guess we uh yeah well
depending what black does if Pawn takes
we take with check
yeah and now this was just
um much preferable if King takes then
Rook D1 is coming
up inside the castle skewer oh that
would be so nice and of course your
queen takes and we went F6
um up a pawn Rook D1 to follow
and yeah it goes to show like even a
strong strong bullet player could uh get
into trouble very very quickly
yeah this is interesting to see because
yeah a lot of
lines and that sort of thing I guess
it's got the reputation of well if
you're over you know this set and healer
then nobody's gonna fall into it but
um
yeah there's a different series of
openings where some lines are
some lines of course are really dubious
but still trappy and then there's other
lines that are a bit more reputable but
still have a lot of like traps to them
um at higher levels so that's yeah for
example doesn't look devious really at
all no not really
um there there are some ways for black
to equalize which maybe I'll I'll avoid
showing in this uh in this session
because then everybody will know
but uh yeah I mean there's just so much
upside uh going for this like there's a
lot of surprise value too because even
Master Level players will not have seen
this before or not have studied this
um yeah so you can catch a lot of
players I'll show you one more trick or
one more benefit with uh
um this Knight C3 move
yeah awesome if you're playing a dragon
player and they play G6 here
this is already considered to be dubious
for black
because you can play D4
and if black just tries to transpose
into an open Sicilian
you can take with the queen
oh and you're just preventing Vision D7
on top of that if they play Knight F6
then you strike immediately with E5 here
yeah that looks and this is a better
version of the line that we just saw
because a knight is hit
and it takes you take the queen first
and then take and
um yeah yeah you're you're threatening
the fork you've taken away casting
rights so this is a nice kind of um
subtle detail to know is that G6 on move
three is actually not a good move
trouble against the J
ET uh I have the best reputation maybe I
know some people in my chat go oh the
dragon's so bad
um but it's actually it's actually
really tricky yeah some people just
judge openings based on like a bad
experience they had but uh yeah it's
it's hard to
label openings as bad or good like they
all have their pros and cons yeah I've
been trying to play the moroxie and that
sort of thing against the dragon but at
the same time I'm not sure if it really
matches my style so yeah marathi's more
positional more like uh you grab space
and then try and be ultra Ultra solid
but yeah it's type of thing that can
still give players trouble and it can
teach you how to play in a more uh
prophylactic positional style as well
but anyway I feel like we covered a lot
of uh a lot of new interesting lines and
um I hope that maybe you can use some of
these uh tricks and traps in your Blitz
Games I'm so excited to use them I'm so
excited I'm definitely gonna have to
uh refresh and probably what this back
to make sure that I'm not forgetting
anything but yeah there was a lot in
there yeah that's a great thing is yeah
you can this will hopefully be saved uh
as a twitch pod but also I might put
this thing on YouTube
um you have a YouTube channel too so
maybe we can split up the content or uh
hopefully yeah I'm I'm pretty bad at
posting to my YouTube I never do it so
maybe maybe I could use this use this a
little bit of content well if you're
watching in the future on YouTube on my
Channel or Hannah's Channel you can
check us out on Twitch or check out
other person's YouTube channel as well
links will be in the description